[CROWD CHANTING]
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS HOLDING
CLIMATE CHANGE RALLIES LIKE THIS
ONE WHERE NEW YORK MAYOR BILL
de BLASIO WAS HECKLED INSIDE
TRUMP TOWER.
MEANWHILE BILL NYE THE SCIENCE
GUY TAKING A SHOT AT REPUBLICANS
FOR NOT SUPPORTING THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
>> WHAT I AM SAYING IS THE
PLANET IS ON [BLEEP] FIRE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS WE CAN
DO TO PUT THEM OUT.
ARE ANY OF THEM FREE?
NO, OF COURSE NOT, NOTHING IS
FREE, YOU IDIOTS PAY TO GROW THE
>> Greg: UP.
I DON'T MIND EXPLAINING
PHOTOSYNTHESIS TO YOU WHEN YOU
WERE 12, BUT YOU ARE ADULTS NOW.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL CRISIS.
SAFETY GLASSES ON [BLEEP].
>> Juan: WOW.
I'VE NEVER SEEN HIM LIKE THAT.
>> Jesse: IF IT WAS A REAL
CRISIS YOU WOULD NOT BE JOKING
LIKE THAT.
THE WHOLE HYSTERIA IS A PERFECT
ENCAPSULATION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> Juan: I LOVE THE PICTURE OF
YOU WITH THE FIRE EXTINGUISHER.
>> Jesse: I WILL USE IT ON YOU
YOU.
IT HITS PSYCHOLOGICAL PROBLEMS,
AND THE POLICY PRIORITIES.
IT MAKES THEM FEEL SUPERIOR, AND
IT MAKES THEM FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
SAVING THE WORLD EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE REALLY NOT.
AND IT ALSO MAKES THEM FEEL LIKE
THEY ARE IN TOUCH WITH NATURE
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE THE ONES
WITH THE CONSERVATIVES DOING THE
HUNTING IN THE FISHING AND THE
AGRICULTURAL AND RURAL AMERICA.
IN TERMS OF POLICY THEY MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL GUILTY AND USE FEAR
IN ORDER TO GET PEOPLE TO DO
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
BECAUSE ALL OF THEIR SOLUTIONS
TO EVERY THING IS THE SAME.
GLOBAL WARMING HYSTERIA IS JUST
THE TROJAN HORSE TO GET INTO ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT THEY WANT TO
DO.
REGULATIONS, TAX HEIGHTS,
RIDICULOUS AMOUNTS OF SPENDING
AND ATTACKING OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES, BECAUSE THIS IS ALL
ABOUT FEELING GUILTY FOR THE
SUCCESS OF CAPITALISM.
THEY CANNOT CONTROL CAPITALISM
AND THAT DRIVES THEM CRAZY.
SO THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTROL
CAPITALISM.
>> Juan: THANK YOU --
>> Jesse: YOU ARE WELCOME.
>> Juan: WE LOVE HEARING FROM
RICHIE RICH.
>> Jesse: I AM THE LOWEST PAID
GUY HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
'S BEFORE YOU PROBABLY ARE.
>> Juan: LISA, WHEN YOU SEE
SOMETHING LIKE BILL NYE GO WILD
LIKE THAT OR YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
RALLIES TODAY, THEY HAD A BIG
ONE IN WASHINGTON AT
HOWARD UNIVERSITY, IT MAKES ME
THINK THAT THE DEMOCRATS SEE
POLITICAL ADVANTAGE IN TALKING
ABOUT THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE LIKE.
REPUBLICANS DON'T SEE AN
ADVANTAGE, YOU JUST HEARD FROM
JESSE, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
PLANS, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
SPEEDS --
>> Lisa: I WOULD SAY THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE DUMB IF THAT IS
WHAT THEY ARE ASSUMING.
I WOULD SAY FOR REPUBLICANS IF
YOU LOOK AT THIS, PART OF THE
REASON WE HAVE BEEN LEADING THE
WORLD AND REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS IS BECAUSE OF
INNOVATION AND NATURAL GAS PAID
FOR THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO MOVE
US ENTIRELY OFF OF FOSSIL FUELS
WHICH MAKES 80% OF THE
UNITED STATES ENERGY
CONSUMPTION, BUT PERTAINING TO
THE RUST BELT STATES, HAVE FUN
GOING OUT TO MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN
AND TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO GOT JOBS THEY ARE, JACK
UP ENERGY PRICES WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT A
LOWER INCOME AMERICANS, SO MUCH
SO THAT YOU HAVE UNION GROUPS
PUTTING OUT STATEMENTS
CONDEMNING THE GREEN NEW DEAL
AND TALKING ABOUT HOW IT IS A
THREAT TO JOBS AND FAMILY AND
THE WAY THAT THEY LIVE THEIR
LIFE.
IF DEMOCRATS THINK THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA, BE MY GUEST, HAVE FUN
WITH IT.
>> Juan: REMEMBER WHEN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ SAID
THIS?
>> HOW MANY YEARS UNTIL THE
WORLD ENDS AGAIN?
WE HAVE 12 YEARS LEFT TO CUT
EMISSIONS BY AT LEAST 50%, IF
NOT MORE.
AND FOR EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO
MAKE A JOKE ABOUT THAT, YOU MAY
LAUGH, BUT YOUR GRANDKIDS WILL
NOT.
>> Juan: THE CONGRESSWOMAN
SAYING THAT THOSE WERE DRY
HUMOR, SHE SAYS THAT SHE WAS
BEING SARCASTIC.
>> Dana: THEY ALWAYS SAY THAT
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP AS WELL.
THEY SAY, OH, HE WILL SAY THAT
THE PRESIDENT WILL SAY THAT
OBVIOUSLY WAS A JOKE.
AND THEY MAKE FUN OF THEM FOR A
PERIOD WAS IT IN THE GREEN NEW
DEAL DOCUMENT THAT IT WAS 12
YEARS?
SO HILARIOUS.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL RALLIES, I'M
PRETTY SURE THAT IS HILARIOUS.
I DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE DAY OR
THE SIGNIFICANCE, WE CAN USE ALL
GLOBAL WARMING, I KNOW THAT YOU
HATE WHEN WE SAY THAT.
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT IS PRETTY
INTERESTING.
I SENT AN ARTICLE TO GREG,
YESTERDAY, BECAUSE I CANNOT
BELIEVE IT.
THE SAME WEEK THEY ARE DOING
GREEN NEW DEAL, IN ILLINOIS THEY
ARE GOING TO INTRODUCE A BILL
INTO THE LEGISLATURE TO TAX
PEOPLE THAT BOUGHT AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE $1,000 APIECE PER YEAR.
GUESS WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT BUYING GAS.
SO THAT MEANS THAT THEY ARE NOT
PAYING INTO THE GAS TAX BUT THEY
ARE STILL ON THE ROAD.
IT IS AN ANTI-CARBON TAX.
THAT IS WHY THE CIRCULAR
ARGUMENT GETS FRUSTRATING FOR
CONSERVATIVES.
>> Juan: WE ALSO HAVE JAY
INSLEE, IN OTHER DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE ON A MOTOR SCOOTER
SAYING THAT THIS COULD BE THE
FUTURE.
YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN SAYING THAT
THERE ARE WAYS THAT COULD LOOK
AT THIS THAT WILL NOT ALIENATE
ANYBODY BECAUSE WE REJOIN THE
PARIS DEAL.
AND THERE HE IS ON A SCOOTER.
THERE IS A MIDDLE GROUND FOR
CONSERVATISM.
>> Greg: THERE IS A HUGE
MIDDLE GROUND, WE ARE IN IT
RIGHT NOW, YOU SEE BILL GATES,
THEY ARE RIGHT THERE.
IT IS CALLED NUCLEAR POWER.
IT IS THE CLEANEST, SAFEST, MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY TYPE OF
ENERGY THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
AND WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT,
THAT IS GOING TO SOLVE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I WANT TO MAKE TWO POINTS.
A COUPLE OF THINGS BUG ME ABOUT
NUCLEAR ENERGY HAVING A BAD RAP
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN ASSOCIATED
TO THE BOMB.
RENEWABLES, WHERE THE ACCIDENTS
ARE FEW.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS, ANYWAY.
RENEWABLE ENERGY IS SOMEHOW
IMMUNE TO A SERIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL REPORTING.
ALMOST LAST TIME ANYBODY READ AN
ARTICLE ABOUT SOLAR POWER WASTE?
SOLAR PANELS CREATE A TON OF
WASTE BY 202050 THERE COULD BE
SEVERAL TONS, AND IT CONTAINS
TOXIC CHEMICALS LIKE CADMIUM
THAT CAN REACH TO THOSE SOIL AND
THE WATER.
SO WHAT I AM SAYING IS NOBODY
TALKS ABOUT THIS, BUT THIS IS
GOING TO BLOW YOUR MIND, DO YOU
REMEMBER WHEN THERE WOULD BE AN
OIL SPILL AND THEY WOULD SHOW
THE LITTLE DUCKS AND EVERYBODY
FELT BAD, THEY WERE CLEANING THE
LITTLE DUCKS, HAVE YOU EVER SEEN
ANY FOOTAGE FROM ANY
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE MILLIONS IN
BILLIONS OF LARGE AND RARE BIRDS
THAT HAVE BEEN MURDERED BY
WIND FARMS?
PROBABLY ONE OF THE LEADING
PREDATORS OF BIRDS, SECOND TO
CATS I BELIEVE.
>> Jesse: BIRD MURDERERS!
>> Greg: WHERE IS PETA?
WHERE ARE THE BIRD WATCHERS?
ARE THEY BOUGHT FOR AND PAID
FOR?
THE GREEN GROUPS?
WE USED TO SEE THE OIL SPILLS,
BUT WE DO NOT SEE THE DEAD
BIRDS, THAT TELLS YOU SOMETHING
ABOUT THE MEDIA.
>> Lisa: WHERE'S THE JUSTICE
FOR THE BIRDS?
IT IS A GREAT POINT.
>> Greg: BILLIONS OF LARGE
BIRDS.
>> Dana: YOU CAN GET
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT, YOU ACTUALLY
ARE FINED.
SO THEY BLAME THE COMPANY IS,
BUT NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THE
ACTUAL BIRDS.
>> Juan: THERE IS SOME CHICKEN
AVAILABLE.
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS ABOUT THE
BIRDS.
>> Greg: YOU DO NOT CARE ABOUT
THE BIRDS, GREAT.
I JUST GAVE YOU ONE, NUCLEAR